Now thus far, we've talked about interdomain
routing BGP, or the border gateway protocol,
as consisting of route advertisements solely between
border routers of adjacent autonomous systems. In fact,
this is a specific type of BGP called external BGP, or EBGP. But in
fact, as we know, each one of these autonomous systems has routers of its own,
inside. Those routers also need to learn, routes to external destinations.
The protocol that is used to transmit routes inside an autonomous system for
external destinations, it's called internal BGP or IBGP. Okay, so to review,
external BGP is responsible for transmitting
routing information between border routers of adjacent
ASs about external destinations. And internal BGP is responsible for
disseminating BGP route advertisements about external destinations to
routers inside any particular AS. Note that the distinction
between IGP and an intra-domain routing protocol or an IGP.